I'm I'm after yours oh my God I'm after
yours we should we should trade these
after the show abolutely um well I'm
going to start with wait congratulations
new son right yes thank you very much
yeah 6 months old 6 months oh are you
sleeping more yeah like he's doing okay
he's sleeping more than we are okay so
you you have a two-year-old right so so
do you do Halloween do you all get all
done up I love Halloween as someone who
dresses up for a living um it's not like
my favorite thing to put on a costume
but of course like my daughter really
wanted us to do Frozen yeah so um so
she's Anna and I am going to be Elsa and
my partner's going to be uh Kristoff and
um so that's fun she has no idea that
Uncle Jonathan is Kristoff yeah that'll
be mindblowing when she figures that out
but oh my God yeah she'd lose it it it's
funny when when because my kids saw an
animated thing that I did and they were
like it broke the wall kind of intensely
sad yeah yeah they saw me in this movie
called ugly dolls and they were like we
don't understand but like and I was like
well you know like Elsa like you know
she's a real person and they were like
what and I was like oh my god oh no what
have I ruined I felt like a horrible
human but you know it's going to happen
soon or later I do that to kids on like
a regular basis when like it's like I'm
sorry you they're like you're old now
what
happened so that was what's so funny my
daughter was obsessed with Chris Martin
for like I mean years and she always
watched the yellow video but he's
younger he's like it's his first single
and so whenever she saw him she's like
well he looks different I go well we age
honey um but yeah but okay enough about
kids so I have to get to this I heard
that you went to Beyonce's Renaissance
tour was it four times
four you I have a question I haven't
been so is it like oh like you can keep
going and you see something new like you
know the o o in Vegas okay yes yes I
would say I mean I haven't seen o oh you
can I can go again and see something you
could yeah I'm sure it's amazing look at
you that's me a Beyonce Whipped Your
Hair yes that's me you look like Patrick
sey and dirty dancing right now what's
happening you just made my life that is
really what with your tank and your
sweaty and the little curl it was like
nice okay okay I mean he is God yeah
yeah it you really can go again and
again I've already got tickets of I've
got them for these two if they're
joining me or not I don't know on the
1st of December when the movie comes out
the concert movie of Beyonce is coming
out the film oh my God after our show
that Friday night I'm not doing anything
after the show I'm not either we have
you might though you I might get you to
go I am so these people I'm like I'm
tired for Beyonce yes but for Beyonce
it's different and that and the concert
and I and I it's it's Transcendent it's
a Transcendent experience it's amazing
conc like before we did this we we do
eight shows a week uh it's a lot of the
same show every night of merily We Roll
Along yeah and watching Beyonce all the
four times that I saw it all the times
that I watched her on YouTube and all
the other cities I love you so much she
brought it to every city no matter which
country which city it was always new she
was always in a different outfit and it
inspired me for the Run of our show that
every time you perform live there's new
people out there you have to bring
everything you've got so it was a real
source of inspiration I'm clearly pass
you have a poster room and I have yes
Crystal Joy Brown who plays Gussy in our
show as a gift got me the ren poster and
she's there in the dressing room I look
at her every day so I had this
experience with you too I saw them at
medicine Square Garden and I I left half
wanting to quit music but but but the
other half of me was so inspired and it
it does it's like man they had been
doing this for so long and it it renews
like a a certain passion inside you yes
completely yeah I love that for you what
have you ever seen anybody that many
times no no no no is there someone you
would
see is there someone you think you would
like if you had the time and know babies
I mean yeah there there's definitely
bands that like but I don't think anyone
like The Hold Steady anyone no oh you're
like like yeah there's definitely yeah I
love J but like there there's definitely
there's definitely people I would but
not probably four times is is stretching
it though is there anyone you would say
that much I don't know maybe like
Barbara strian like oh I've never seen
her me neither I would die to see her we
should go if she comes to New York we
are going to go you think I'm kidding
but I'm going to call serious we're
going to go I don't feel like she does
shows though I don't know I'm just
saying like if we put it out in the
universe did you see the thing she did
the music and memories thing she did
like Netflix or something it was some
kind of thing oh my yeah she did it in
Brooklyn this concert yeah and her new
book's about to come out oh really yes I
I want her on the show I was like wait I
was like we share a birthday I love you
um do I get any appoints there wait the
song I picked for you for your Spotify
playlist is a barber song is an obscure
Barber song which how obscure what's it
called oh you're not going to it's
called Napoleon oh I don't know that one
giving up I feel like there's a complex
I feel like is this a fun song cuz you
could go a lot of ways with Napoleon
it's a very fun song okay okay okay did
y'all know each other before you got on
stage because I feel like you even The
Voice coaches they have us have like a
dinner or get together for a drinks or
something if you've never met each other
and they have us kind of you know hang
out that would have been nice oh you did
was the first day just oh no we we've
known each other for a long time um but
you know we knew we were doing this for
I don't know a year or something so we
all um we got each other's info and
started sending video text messages back
and forth to get to know each other
which I was slightly stressed out by
because these guys send like very
relaxed natural sort of two three minute
videos giving an update and I was always
just watching them and when I would try
and send one back I would have to
restart it like three times cuz I'm like
I'm saying I'm and are too much or I'm
saying
like and then they would just I would
feel like I had to make notes and it's
like what everything did they say in
their
videos I have become more relaxed about
it since then thank God good for you
yeah it's real growth
thank it's a great video I do now thank
you well he worked on them they should
be pretty good I've been yeah rehearsing
apparently I recently moved here I love
working thank you but what do you all
like about working here do you like it
do you like living here and working here
I mean anytime I get to work in New York
it's kind of the dream like I I live
here most of the time I mean U pretty
yeah I live here now basically I think I
can say that um and uh yeah anytime I
get to also here and just like come home
to my place at the end of the day and be
in the you know West Village it's it's
awesome I love this city so I feel
really lucky to be able to live here
raising kids here is kind of fun it's
amazing think that would Happ much for
them here yeah cuz I I was living in La
too for a while and came back here for
this and oh my God like the parks and
the museums and taking her you know on
the bus and on the subway like it's so
fun we just we have such a full life
here with kids it's fantastic yeah do
you love it obsessed I love okay yeah I
love it I put on my bike helmet I get on
my bicycle you're one of those brave
people I haven't I haven't done that yet
it's so I I recommend maybe in Central
Park first before you move to the
streets I have a bite coming and I just
I also see the ER in my future I just I
don't know yeah yeah yeah I just feel
like people can drive crazy here a
little bit yeah yeah it's it's intense
in those bike Lanes but it's also
beautiful and incredible and riding the
bike to the theater my favorite thing
about New York is the Live Theater that
like eight times a week there's all of
these people
in this like small area of New York
Performing these plays it's such a
special place it's that's an amazing way
to look at it too yeah then and just
it's not going to last forever that
show's going to leave so it's like you
want to catch it like the energy of that
is pretty magical exactly yeah well
explain to everybody if that doesn't
know marily We Roll Along what is it
about who wants to who wants to
Backstage Jonathan go this you were all
like not me yeah so merily We Roll Along
is a story of three friends a friendship
that spans 20 years but it's a musical
music and lyrics by Steven sanheim
incredible composer of the woods and
sunay in the park with George and uh the
unique thing or one of the unique things
about the show is that it's about a
20-year friendship but it's told
backwards so it starts at the end of the
friendship and goes all the way back to
the beginning when they first met and
the music is amazing is
amazing so it I know I haven't seen it
my executive producer is like get to the
I'm just my kids just got in school and
there's all these parents te guys so I
haven't been able to catch wor I know
but there's so many shows I have a list
with my girlfriends for our night our we
have one night out come let us know but
no pressure no I'm not going to let you
know because you're like me you don't
like to know when people come let us
know they won't tell me I'll find out
later then that's fine yeah okay we are
identical in this cuz I don't like when
people tell me people are at my show
because I will one think about it the
whole time and then I will search for
them yes I I was told recently there was
a moment like 3 weeks ago where uh
Merill Street was supposed to be coming
to the show for the night you never tell
someone Merill Street and T right and I
accidentally found out and I was like
she she didn't end up coming I think she
had something else to busy woman but
like but uh but I for the whole time
because that's the thing when if I know
that like an anonymous famous person is
in the crowd I'm fine with it as soon as
I know specifically who it is I keep
thinking like oh God you know Robert
dairo is out there thinking watching my
acting tonight that's a terrifying
though but he is a psychopath and he
likes you're
opposite I love to know when I when I
was doing Hamilton with Lynn we shared a
dressing room and I I used to be like I
don't know if I like to know or not but
Lynn obsessively wanted to know who was
in the audience and it would bring him
so much joy and it would Infuse his
performance with he used it he used it
so like when Eminem was there who's like
one of his rap Heroes he he was like
rapping in a in a slightly harder way
when Merill was there we were all giving
like very
acted Sophie's Choice level yes was very
we were like suddenly conscious of
everything that we were doing with our
hands uh that's like the vibe I feel
when I am completely him no you like you
right you like know I'm kind of in the
middle like I if I if I find out I mean
and the truth is like at marily we've
had so many people come then it becomes
normal it kind of has started to become
normal but I used to be like him and be
like don't tell me or I'll be the entire
show thinking how bad I am yeah we
thought Tom Hanks was there the other
day he was not we had it confir there
was not him there's a guy who looks a
lot like him who sing shows in New York
[Music]
[Applause]
doubleganger thank you guys y have a
great night I'm going
home